ومسلسل كمان سر الباتع يعني هو متاخد من
روايه عميقه جدا ومؤثره جدا وناس بتحبها
جدا
هي الروايه طبعا خالد يوسف طوارها وعمل
مسلسل بشكل مختلف انت شايفه ازاي يعني هو
اولا مش هذهع سر اعتقد انه خالد صرح بيها
قبل كده انه ده حلم عند خالد من 20 سنه
انا وخالد اصدقاء جدا والحقيقه ان هو كان
عنده حلم سر الباتا حتى كان عنده اختيارات
لموضوعات ربما تكون جماهيريه اكتر لكن سر
الباتع هو انت عارفه
المجنون بتاع الروايه نفسها بيتكلم عن
عظمه هذا الشعب والباتع دي اللي هي يعني
بتحمل معاني عديده ومتعدده جوا هذا الشعب
اللي جواه اصرار وسر كبير جدا جدا بيخليه
زي ما كان بعض الجمل في في الروايه بتقول
هو في العمل الفني ايضا انه انه صعب انك
تغيري هويته وصعب انك تهزم يه حتى وان بدا
ليكي لبعض من الوقت انك قد ملتي من هذا
الشعب لكن طبعا على العكس تماما شعب قوي
وقادر يواجه كل المحل بكافه اشكالها
وانواعها وواجه كل الاعداء